[Musica]
I giovani non si formano più le nuove
generazioni non hanno voglia di
informarsi i ragazzi sono superficiali
quando si tratta di informazioni Chi di
voi ha sentito almeno una volta nella
vita una di questa affermazione
OK Praticamente tutti anche io questa
affermazione le sento di continuo
soprattutto da quando tre anni fa
guardandomi attorno parlando con i miei
coetanei mi sono accorto che nessuno di
questi era informato su quello che
succedeva nel mondo me compreso e quindi
mi sono posto delle domande ma perché
questo succede È davvero è proprio vero
che non abbiamo voglia di informarci e
ci siamo anche dati delle risposte io
con i miei soci Daniele Enrico e Marco
nel secondo noi la nostra generazione ha
una generazione molto curiosa non è per
niente svogliata e anzi a tantissima
voglia di fare
e quindi questa risposta è per lui sono
state il fatto che
le nuove generazioni in media
tradizionali parlano una lingua
completamente diversa da quella che
parliamo noi e utilizzano dei media per
comunicare molto diversi da quelli che
noi utilizziamo tutti i giorni e quindi
abbiamo creato una community circa 3
anni fa una community che poi è
diventata una startup il nostro
obiettivo è sempre stato quello di
avvicinare i giovani a tematiche di loro
interesse ma anche a volte di loro
scarso interesse proprio per anche
avvicinarla a questo
abbiamo voluto avvicinarli a queste
tematiche proprio perché abbiamo visto
che c'era delle volte confusione in
queste tematiche delle volte come
ambiente come diritti civili come
Diritti Sociali
queste tematiche un po' di tempo di anni
fa non erano di loro interesse mentre
adesso con il nostro lavoro e anche il
lavoro di tantissimi altri colleghi sono
sempre più vicini a noi abbiamo voluto
fare sfruttando il potenziale dei social
media e anche utilizzando un linguaggio
attuale è molto vicino a quello che
parliamo di tutti i giorni
questi sono alcuni numeri per quanto
riguarda il nostro media abbiamo mezzo
milione di persone che ci seguono il 95%
sono under 35 i contenuti vengono visti
da milioni di persone ogni settimana e
questo è giusto qualche esempio di
contenuto che abbiamo pubblicato in
questi anni Eh i relativi risultati Ma
questo perché succede perché realmente i
giovani sono distanti dai media
tradizionali Ci sono tantissimi motivi a
me piace fare ehm Diciamo che quando mi
hanno invitato al The decks la prima
cosa che ho fatto è stato fatto una
ricerca su internet sono andato al pc
una delle cose che so fare meglio è
stato frugare al PC e ho notato questo
studio dell'agicomo veramente molto
interessante che si chiama
l'informazione a prova di giovani che
dice la fuga delle nuove generazioni dei
mezzi tradizionali evidentemente legata
un'offerta che non soddisfa le esigenze
informative dei più giovani è una vera e
propria dipendenza tendenziale verso una
sola Fonte informativa la rete la prima
volta che ho letto questo studio
sinceramente dico la verità non ci ho
capito granché quindi l'ho letto Uno due
tre quattro volte e io ho capito
benissimo cosa intendesse mi trovo
assolutamente d'accordo e a me piace
rendere le cose difficili piace renderle
semplici e soprattutto alla portata di
tutti quindi traduciamolo i giovani si
formano solamente da un media il web è
per web intendiamo social media e siti
web Ma questo perché succede succede per
tantissimi motivi io ho riassunto
Diciamo in sei punti primo Tra questi la
mancanza di ispirazione quando noi
andiamo ad usufruire di un contenuto che
sia una notizia che sia un qualsiasi
tipo di contenuto vogliamo essere
ispirati da questo vogliamo prenderne
valore e vogliamo anche farci una una
nostra opinione a riguardo è questo è
fondamentale ogni volta che noi giovani
abbiamo bisogno di ognuno dei giovani
vogliamo leggere dei contenuti Inoltre
si trattano poche tematiche sociali è
come se
stiamo capendo che il mondo non sta
andando nella direzione in cui vorremmo
che andasse
e quindi vogliamo capire il perché e
vogliamo capirlo proprio per poterlo
cambiare nel corso degli anni
e poi si parla si tende a seguire sempre
le 3s del giornalismo come ben sapete le
trecce del giornalismo sono lo stesso
sangue e soldi e se andiamo a vedere i
video tradizionali La maggior parte dei
contenuti che questi pubblicano Sono
esattamente coerenti con queste tre con
queste tre regole
un altro fenomeno è quello della
polarizzazione per motivi di tempo o per
motivi di spazio si tende a dire che una
cosa è bianca o nera quella persona è
buona o è cattiva quella cosa è giusta o
sbagliata ma non è mai così soprattutto
quando si tratta di informazione ci sono
tantissime scale di grigi e grazie
all'online grazie ai media ai nuovi
media se la possibilità di andare ad
approfondire gratuitamente tutte queste
notizie tutti questi tutti questi
contenuti qua e quindi l'invito andare a
andare a cercare tutte queste tantissime
scale di grigi per avere un'informazione
coerente e corretta al 100%
la comunicazione visiva
uno studio di Microsoft Canada Dice che
la nostra soglia di attenzione è minore
ad 8 secondi è giusto per capirci quella
di un pesce rosso secondo lo stesso
studio sarebbe di 9 secondi Quindi
abbiamo una soglia di attenzione minore
di un pesce rosso e quindi la
comunicazione visiva in questo senso fa
tutto senza una comunicazione visiva
diretta
È coinvolgente non si va da nessuna
parte
poi online Esistono le Community esiste
la possibilità interagire quindi se ha
la possibilità di parlare con persone
confrontarsi se ha la possibilità di
sentire nuovi pareri e anche cambiare la
nostra opinione con nuove informazioni e
questa il fatto che chiunque possa
scrivere su su internet sia una cosa
bellissima sia una cosa molto molto
pericolosa ma vedremo meglio dopo perché
e poi l'età dei giornalisti o comunque
di che comunica limitazioni se andiamo a
pensarci quanti conduttori televisivi
giovani conosciamo
veramente pochi Idem chi scrive
che scrive nei media è spesso un adulto
e infatti di conseguenza il pubblico È
esattamente quello Ma quindi qua
potremmo dire Ok allora andiamo tutti
quanti online siamo tutti quanti felici
e tutto perfetto online ma purtroppo
nemmeno l'online è tutto rose e fiori
e poi mi piace fare una metafora Ovvero
lo stomaco delle nuove generazioni è
molto diverso da quello delle vecchie e
i piatti cucinati dai media tradizionali
non sono facilmente digeribili per gli
stomaci dei più giovani come stai
dicendo prima Non hai non è tutto rose e
fiori
primo problema dell'online le fake news
chiunque può scrivere chiunque può dire
la propria E questo porta a leggere
veramente spesso veramente
tante volte notizie false o parzialmente
veritiere E quindi cosa dovremmo fare il
mio consiglio è quello di cercare
tantissime fonti di andare a cercare più
fonti possibili io dico almeno 4/5 e
soprattutto nazionali e internazionali
il metodo più banale ma è anche quello
più efficace secondo problema del
dell'online e la camera Adecco ovvero
l'algoritmo dei social media ci conosce
benissimo ci conosce meglio di quanto
noi conosciamo noi stessi proprio perché
noi diamo degli input a social media
mettendo mi piace commentando twittando
requietando Ecco qualcuno delle volte
Una volta ho parlato con un amico di
questo e mi ha detto Sì ok ma io non
interagisco social media Io ce l'ho e
basta ma anche solamente per il fatto
che davanti ad un contenuto ci stiamo 5
secondi davanti ad un altro contenuto ci
stiamo 15 secondi quello è un dato
preciso che fa capire l'algoritmo che
quel tipo di contenuto ci interessa più
dell'altro e questo crea una bolla
una bolla che
una bolla che aiuta l'algoritmo a
mostrarci solamente contenuti coerenti
con la nostra idea e quindi ci crea
questa bolla dove noi pensiamo una cosa
e ci sembra che tutti quanti pensino
questo ed è una cosa molto molto
pericolosa anche qui il mio consiglio è
quello di seguire pagina
comunque contenuti con una diversa linea
di pensiero anche qua quello di
confrontarsi con altre persone Anche qua
quello di
sentire appunto diverse linee di
pensiero Quindi anche qua la
comunicazione fa da padrona poi l'agogna
mediatica banalmente l'evoluzione della
Gogna medievale Ho letto da poco un
libro molto interessante che si chiama
socialbility e Questo spiega benissimo
come prima le Community esistevano per
un obiettivo preciso quindi si andava a
pregare sono le Community che andavano a
pregare la community esisteva per andare
a mangiare per andare a cacciare Adesso
invece le Community se ci pensiamo
esistono ma senza un obiettivo comune
ovvero tutti quanti noi la mattina
apriamo i social media scrolliamo
scrolliamo scrolliamo fino a che un
qualcosa non attira la nostra attenzione
e spesso quello che attira la nostra
attenzione è una persona attaccata una
persona presa di Mira dalla massa
e non è così difficile far parte della
massa che prende di mira la persona
perché non abbiamo di fronte a noi il
contesto a 360 gradi e per avere il
contesto preciso a 360 gradi è
necessario andare a sentire anche
l'opinione di quella persona altrimenti
qua andiamo veramente a fare la Gogna
mediatica ovvero secondo la Treccani la
Gogna mediatica e l'esposizione al
pubblico disprezzo dei personaggi Messi
al centro dell'attenzione dai mezzi di
informazione ma senza che ci sia una una
condanna ufficiale Quindi senza che ci
siano un processo ufficiale Quindi è una
condanna senza processo
quindi per concludere se in mezzo Sei
media tradizionali per una lingua
completamente diversa da quella che
parliamo noi tutti i giorni e al tempo
stesso comunque l'online ancora così
tante lacune così tanti pericoli cosa
potremo fare potremmo rimanere qua
Potremmo rimanere qua a parlarne per ore
ci sono tantissime
cose che potremmo fare per migliorare
questa questa situazione ma io voglio
dare giusto uno spunto ovvero quello
dell'Unione di questi due mondi ovvero
in questo momento è presente un Gap
generazionale se andiamo a pensarci c'è
proprio un Gap tra le generazioni
veramente enorme quasi incolmabile cioè
le generazioni hanno una visione tra
generazioni sia una visione
completamente diversa
E quindi cosa si può fare si può andare
a prendere l'autorevolezza del
tradizionale La professionalità del
tradizionale è unirla invece con il
linguaggio fresco è immediato del nuovo
e sono convinto che facendo questo tipo
di lavoro si possa andare a colmare
piano piano questo Gap si possa andare a
dare una visione più omogenea di quello
che è il mondo in questo momento
e sono convinto che questo si possa fare
solamente tramite la comunicazione la
corretta comunicazione Grazie
[Applauso]